[موسيقى]
النساء كنا اول من خرجنا الى الشارع
وخلعنا الحجاب في تظاهرات سلميه واشعلنا
فيها النار وقمنا بقص شعرهن على الرغم من
مخاطر الاغتصاب والسجن والضرب والزنج بهن
في مراكز اعاده تاهيل النفس والقتل هذه
الشجاعه نقلت عدوها الى الاخرين الامر
الفريد الذي يميزها والذي دعا كثيرين منا
الى تسميتها ثوره بقياده المراه هي ان
المراه الايرانيه تمكنت من تحفيز المجتمع
بكمله بفهم مسائل المساواه بين الجنسين
وكل حقوق الانسان الاساسيات الاخرى
[موسيقى]
كانت مهسا بمثابه القشه التي قسمت ظهر
البعير باشكال عده القمع المستمر منذ فتره
طويله
ومسعتقلت لانها ارتدت الحجاب بشكل غير
ملائم فكروا في ذلك كيف يمكن تعريفه لا
يمكن تعريفه الامر موضوع وعشوائي حاله
الكثير من القوانين التي وضعها النظام من
اجل السيطره على النساء في ايران وهذه
اللحظه من الزمن لا تدور حول منسف حسب
الحولك كافه الحقوق ومحاولات النظام
لاسكات المراه منذ اكثر من اربعين عاما
[موسيقى]
اعتقد ان النساء ازدادت شجاعتهن واصبح
الرجال داعمين لهن اكثر كلما قتل النظام
الايراني عدد اكبر ازدادت عزيمه الشعب
يقشعر بدني عندما اشاهد ذلك بعد ما يقوم
النظام باعدام احد المتظاهرين نرى والدي
القتيل في اليوم التالي يحاولان الجنازه
الى تظاهره كبيره
[موسيقى]